how's it going raise money back welcome
today we're going to draw bad fictions
it's a new series that I like to call
drawing poor drawing smut because let's
be honest that's what everyone wants to
see you here on this channel
alright well the sooner we can get
started as soon we can get rid of that
array
it's nice you bros on twitter what kind
of fan fiction is do you want to see you
and Edgar done and Gaia has that weird
mentally handicapped seal kind of I
guess what I'm doing is I'm bending over
with that impeccable Swedish putz that
I'm famous for and of course I wear high
heels that looks like chicken legs and
I'm skinny and beautiful and flexing I
think this is flexing I never tried it
so I wouldn't know and my face is did a
360 aren't you glad you clicked on this
video yet Edgar and 45 fan fiction done
next fan fiction Zoe and Alfie I know
them so I feel like it's not it's not
bad for me to draw it okay
so I'll I'll use that picture as a
reference and then I'll try and just go
with the same style I I suppose I'm
actually trying here this is the saddest
thing I've seen in my life
all right no more referencing the met
this is this in true inspiration she
kind of grabs the the tongue hi shad
selfie fine art done who's Larry oh this
this is just the blood of your you know
what you don't want to know well well
well you learn something new every day
Larry fan fiction so Larry is Lewis and
Harry okay
yes there is romance alright melt mental
image oh god what have I done
they were so happy not long ago I don't
know if that's its boobs or his arms yet
I have I honestly haven't figured it out
aren't you jealous of my drawing skills
though still they can be boobs they can
be arms no one knows
this could be him having four ah I like
it
the ship has sailed hashtag Larry
beautiful you and trick oh hell yeah
I fantasized about this one a long time
I have what they call a quad but this is
him he's holding a pen by the way I
didn't really specify what he's about to
do with that pen no completely different
thing all right what's the hashtag she
licks its shipped what ships
she'll be sail tonight all the you bros
will decide sanic and ken now I don't
want to brag but I'm not the best Sonic
fan art writer of all time if you don't
like my Sonic then that's your fault
what am I doing here brace I love my
life so much can actually love SATA
sonic so this is actually kind of
fitting ken this is testing if it's good
good products
man I'm so mature how old am i again
better than most sonic fan art I went
there my god the ships are coming in at
the speed of light dad and Phil that has
to be a classic YouTube ship what is a
ship name though drill I just made that
[ __ ] up here we go Dan and Phil this is
how I picture it but your brothers can
interpret it either way you want giving
that thumbs up for consent
there's a subtle miserably - Phil's face
I love it sorry Dan spades yeah fail I
didn't know Phil was a slight this is
weird I feel like this is a little weird
these are real people that's why it's
really turning me out I'm just kidding
Phil is a little nervous about his
performance but I'm sure it'll be fine
I bet there is a name for it already but
now we changed it ship has sailed
Phil's but like it though so it's okay
the ship has sailed
beautiful what's the next ship Beauty
cry of course
they wouldn't be a good fanfic without
some boutique riding my boobs are a
little bigger than Christ this is just
how I dream about it some people think I
have a six-pack but I actually have what
the [ __ ] is happening down there PAC
same training as the one who did 300
give the thumbs up for consent and there
we go
we're good to go let's not forget my
mole there we go and my beautiful
luscious Swedish hair and the fact that
I'm a unicorn and the fact I cry lost
one of his boobs in the war the great
youtuber battle cry only has one boob
now cry of learn to live with it he is a
little sad about it though he also lost
his genitals and had to replace it with
an eel which is also part of the
youtuber battle beautiful the ship has
sailed ladies morose
the ship has long sailed I bet people
are gonna call me weird for all this but
you bros do it all the time
ah of course pigeon and spoon the
greatest ship of all time hashtag spit
Gian there we go
what am I doing here Bros he's seaming
sin to grab his ass he already got a
half boner
okay this is getting too weird alright
hope you bros enjoyed the fan fictions
the fan art sorry the fact the ships
whatever it is we did today I hope you
boys enjoyed it if you did go ahead and
hit that like button thank you for doing
so and thank you for being a brow it's
the sky camera today and I will see you
bros in the next one
stay awesome as always